moi qui espérais plus jamais revoir vos
visages wesh poteaux ont débarqué les
filles personnes croyaient à la reprise
de john street mais coup de bol vous
avait cartonné
alors du coup nos services ont investi
des sommes monstre pour que john street
continue sur ses sommets
c'est le petit problème les coréens ont
racheté leur église
alors on vous des ménages en face aux
fans de james strict mais ni qu'on vous
aller à l'université
c'est grave ou mortelle
[Musique]
on va faire le tour des amphis des
assauts se rencarder sur la cam et
débusquer le dealer
je viens juste à se faire des potes et
des jeux à boire je vois pas ce que ça
donne
mais comme account hôpitaux ouais j'en
rihanna et chris brown
toi tu danses comme un dieu il ya quand
même des fois je te trouve trop méchant
on a raté notre attention
brigade de jam street on va te jobs
véhicule en plein dans l'arrêt